HIGHLIGHTS.
FIRST, WE DO START WITH BIG
BREAKING NEWS.
NANCY PELOSI, SPEAKER IN NAME
ONLY FINALLY AGREED TO SEND OUT
THE ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT TO
THE SENATE TOMORROW.
THE DEMOCRATS KNOW THESE
ARTICLES ARE SO LAUGHABLY WEAK,
THEY HAVE NOT DECIDED TO INCLUDE
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE NOT
PRESENTED DURING THEIR SHAM
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDING.
THIS 25TH HOUR OF DESPERATION
REEKS OF MORE PATHETIC PSYCHOSIS
AND ARRANGEMENT.
GET THIS COME ALL THE NEW
DOCUMENTS, THEY CENTER AROUND
QUID PRO QUO AND JOE, HIS SON,
ZERO EXPERIENCE, HUNTER.
NOW, REMEMBER WHAT I'VE ALWAYS
SAID.
A PRESIDENT, ANY PRESIDENT DOES
HAVE A SWORN DUTY TO FAITHFULLY
EXECUTE THE LAWS OF THE LAND.
PUT THAT IN THE COMPARTMENT IN
YOUR BRAIN.
BUT IF YOU READ THESE NEW
FINDINGS, YOU WILL QUICKLY SEE
HOW POLITICALLY SKEWED THEIR NEW
INFORMATION, THEIR TROVE OF
DOCUMENTS IS.
LOOK AT THIS MATERIAL WE ARE
LEARNING TONIGHT.
YOU ARE NOT GETTING THE BILLION
UNLESS YOU FIRE THE PROSECUTOR
INVESTIGATING HUNTER.
THEY MENTIONED THAT NUMEROUS
TIMES.
HE'S INNOCENT.
OKAY.
I DON'T EVEN THINK THEY BELIEVE
THAT TO BE HONEST.
THEY HAVE EXONERATED JOE AND
HUNTER.
THEY DEFINITIVELY SAY THE
UKRAINIAN PROSECUTORS, NOW, HE
WAS THE CORRUPT ONE.
ALL WHILE TOTALLY --
YOU'VE GOT SIX HOURS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE ARE NOT GOING TO GIVE YOU
THE MILLION DOLLARS.
YOU ARE NOT THE PRESIDENT.
THAT'S WHAT I TOLD YOU.
YOU'RE NOT GETTING A MILLION
DOLLARS.
I THINK IT WAS WHAT, SIX HOURS.
YOU ARE NOT GETTING THE MONEY.
WELL, SON OF A --
HE GOT FIRED.
>> Sean: PROSECUTORS ARE
INVESTIGATING HUNTER, BIDEN'S
SON, ZERO EXPERIENCE, HUNTER.
REMEMBER, HUNTER WAS GETTING
PAID MILLIONS AND MILLIONS TO
SERVE ON A CORRUPT ENERGY
COMPANY.
HE HAD NO EXPERIENCE IN OIL,
GAS, WHATSOEVER.
NONE.
SO THE DEMOCRATS, DO THEY BOTHER
TO LOOK INTO WHY ZERO EXPERIENCE
HUNTER WAS GETTING RICH,
COMPLIMENTS OF THE SHADY
UKRAINIAN COMPANY, ALL WHILE HIS
FATHER WAS IN CHARGE OF UKRAINE
POLICY?
NOW, FOR THE SIMPLEST
EXPLANATION, LET'S JUST GO TO
HUNTER BIDEN HIMSELF,
49-YEAR-OLD KID.
SPEAKER YOU DIDN'T HAVE ANY
EXTENSIVE KNOWLEDGE OF NATURAL
GAS.
>> NO, BUT I THINK I HAD AS MUCH
KNOWLEDGE AS ANY ONE ELSE WHO
WAS ON THE BOARD.
SPEAKER YOU DID NOT LIST THE
FACT THAT YOU ARE THE SON.
HOW DO YOU THINK THAT PLAYED?
>> I THINK IT'S IMPOSSIBLE FOR
ME WITHOUT SAYING I'M THE SON OF
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES APPEARS BIGGER IF
YOUR NAME WASN'T BIDEN, DO YOU
THINK YOU WOULD HAVE BEEN ASKED
TO BE ON THE BOARD?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
PROBABLY NOT.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS I WOULD HAVE HAPPENED IN
MY LIFE IF MY LAST NAME WASN'T
BIDEN.
>> Sean: IF YOUR LAST NAME
WASN'T BIDEN, WOULD YOU HAVE
GOTTEN MILLIONS AND MILLIONS?
PROBABLY NOT.
CAN YOU THINK OF ANY COMPANY
THAT WOULD PAY MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS WITH ZERO
EXPERIENCE?
THE ONLY COMPANY THAT WOULD PAY
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS TO SOMEONE
WITH ZERO EXPERIENCE IS A
COMPANY TRYING TO CORRUPTLY BUY,
INFLUENCE, AND IN THIS CASE, IT
WOULD BE HIS FATHER, THE
SECOND-HIGHEST RANKING AT THE
TIME, ELECTED OFFICIAL IN
AMERICA, QUID PRO QUO COMPANY JE
AMERICA, QUID PRO QUO COMPANY J.
TONIGHT, THERE IS NEW BOGUS
EVIDENCE BROUGHT TO YOU BY WHO?
IT'S CAUGHT ON TAPE.
CONSPIRING WITH REAL RUSSIANS TO
DIG UP DIRT ON DONALD TRUMP'S
INFLUENCE IN THE ELECTION.
THE ABUSIVELY BIASED, CORRUPT
SCHIFF.
NOW, DON'T BUY INTO THIS
CHARADE.
THIS IS AN ASSAULT ON YOUR BODY,
AN ASSAULT ON OUR CONSTITUTION.
REMEMBER, THE SOLE POWER, IT'S
RIGHT THERE IN THE CONSTITUTION.
IT IS NOT YOUR ROLE TO SORT
THROUGH AND INVESTIGATE AND FIX
AND REINVESTIGATE DOCUMENTS THE
SLOPPY HOUSE DEMOCRATS NEGLECTED
TO INCLUDE IN THEIR BOGUS
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT.
THE CONSTITUTION CLEARLY STATES
THE HOUSE HAS THE SOLE POWER TO
IMPEACH.
IT'S NOT THE ROLE OF THE SENATE
TO INTERVIEW WITNESSES.
THEY IMPEACHED HIM.
NOW, HOUSE MANAGERS WILL PRESENT
THEIR CASE TO YOU.
THIS IS THEIR CASE.
THIS IS THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL
ROLE.
A MEMBER, IT WAS SO URGENT THAT
THEY DID THIS JUST BEFORE
CHRISTMAS AND URGENTLY WENT ON
VACATION.
SENATE TRIES THE HOUSE ARTICLE.
THAT'S IT.
THAT'S YOUR JOB.
AFTER STALLING THE SO-CALLED
"URGENT PROCESS" AS A PART OF A
BIZARRE STRATEGY,
MITCH McCONNELL HAD TO DO HIS
JOB AND FULFILL HIS
CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE.
THE PROCESS IS MOVING FORWARD
WITHOUT ANY CONCESSIONS FROM THE
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER.
PELOSI LOOKS STUPID AND ACTED
DELUSIONAL AS USUAL.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS, A VERY
ANGRY NANCY IS NOW TELLING HER
COLLEAGUES MITCH McCONNELL
MIGHT BE A RUSH AND OPT BECAUSE
HE WANT TO PLAY NICE WITH HER.
"AMERICAN ELECTIONS SHOULD BE
DECIDED BY THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
NOT BY THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT."
RETWEET IF YOU AGREE.
WHILE MATT, SHE FINALLY
DISCOVERED THE RUSSIAN
DOSSIER.
SHE TALKING ABOUT THAT?
I DOUBT IT.
WE HAVE ANOTHER ELECTION.
BASED ON THESE TWO ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT, RAN THROUGH WITHOUT
ANY BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
SHE DIDN'T GET THAT.
REMEMBER, JUST LAST YEAR,
CLAIMING THERE NEEDS TO BE A
BIPARTISAN INITIATIVE.
WHAT WE SAW OVER THE PAST 100
DAYS WAS PURELY A PARTISAN
SCHEME TO NEGATE THE VOTE OF
OVER 62 MILLION.
POLITICAL HATCHET JOB EXTENDS
FROM TWO VERY SIMPLE BASIC
FACTS.
ONE, THE LEFT WILL NOT EVER
ACCEPT THE RESULTS OF THE 2016
ELECTION.
GUESS WHAT, 294 DAYS, YOU GET TO
SHOCK THE WORLD AGAIN.
DEMOCRATS AND THE MOB AND THE
MEDIA.
AND TWO, THEY ARE SCARED
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL DESTROY
THEM IN 2020.
IMAGINE FOR A SECOND, IF THE
NEWS SAYS ON ELECTION NIGHT, WE
CANNOT PROJECT DONALD TRUMP HAS
BEEN REELECTED THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
IT'S JUST WORTH THE PRICE OF
ADMISSION.
THEY HAVE EVERY REASON TO BE
WORRIED.
FAR AWAY FROM THE D.C. SWAB AND
THE COASTAL ELITES IN NEW YORK,
SAN FRANCISCO, L.A., JOHN MARK.
WE HAD A PACKED STADIUM LAST
NIGHT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THE FIRST LADY,
THEY WALKED OUT.
CHEERS, CHANTS.
FOUR MORE YEARS.
CHANTING, USA.
LET'S WATCH THE POWERFUL MOMENT.
TAKE IT ALL IN.
IF I WAS A DEMOCRAT, I DON'T
THINK I'D LIKE THIS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[CHANTING USA]
>> Sean: WOW.
FOR MORE YEARS, USA.
WHEN YOU SHOW UP TO THE POLLS,
ASK YOURSELF, ARE YOU BETTER OFF
THAN YOU WERE THREE YEARS AGO?
THE ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION IS
CRYSTAL CLEAR.
ENDING BURNHAM SOME REGULATION.
HE RENEGOTIATED ALL THOSE TRADE
DEALS HE SAID HE WANTED FREE AND
FAIR TRADE.
HE SECURED FUNDING FOR THE
BORDER WALL.
EXPECT 400 MILES BY NOVEMBER
NEXT YEAR.
HE EMPOWERED AMERICAN ENERGY.
WE ARE NOW A NET EXPORTER OF
ENERGY, THE WORLD'S LARGEST
PRODUCER OF OIL.
THAT HASN'T HAPPENED IN 75
EUROS.
DON'T FORGET, THE WORLD IS A
SAFER PLACE NOW THAT BAGHDADI
AND SOLEIMANI ARE DEAD.
THE UNITED STATES NOW HAS THE
SINGLE LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
SINCE 1969.
SOME OF YOU WEREN'T EVEN BORN
YET.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN LIFTED OFF OF
FOOD STAMPS AND INCOMES ARE
RISING ALL ACROSS THE BOARD.
NOW, WHAT HAS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY DONE THE LAST
FOUR YEARS TO CONTRIBUTE TO YOUR
PROSPERITY?
WELL, I CAN REPORT TO YOU
TONIGHT, ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
THEY HAVE WIND, THEY HAVE
COMPLAINED, THEY HAVE LIED, THEY
HAVE SKIMMED, THEY HAVE PUSHED
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
THEY OBSESS OVER ONE CONSPIRACY
THEORY AND WHEN IT'S WRONG, THEY
MOVE ON TO ANOTHER ONE, EVEN
MADE EXCUSES FOR AN EVIL URANIAN
MADE EXCUSES FOR AN EVIL URANIAI
MADE EXCUSES FOR AN EVIL URANIAA
MADE EXCUSES FOR AN EVIL URANIAN
REGIME.
BY THE WAY, PRETTY PATHETIC FOR
YOUR TRACK RECORD FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.